so the first thing you need to do uh if
you haven't done this already is go to
learn.omixlogic.com
once you go here
this is the primary platform you're
going to utilize to access your courses
your lessons and all the information
within this training model
and once you get to this page all you
have to do is click on register for free
should be front and center here below
this information
if you don't have an account already
just click on this little create an
account
it'll change how this window looks from
sign in to sign up and it'll have one or
two extra boxes to fill in some
information like your name your email
and the password you would like to use
if you once you make your account make
sure you sign in so i'm going to go
ahead and do that make sure you hit sign
in once you've entered your information
and i'll take you to a page like this
now i recommend
for the easiest interaction with
everything if you're looking for the
programs you sign up for to click on
your profile name so it'll say here
it'll list your email welcome back click
on that and it'll take you to your
profile
this is what your profile should look
like you may not have a description here
but you're welcome to add one in and
you're also welcome to link any of your
socials
to your account
this is down here you'll see your level
most of you that are starting fresh will
be beginner and you'll have you
shouldn't have many points to get points
all you have to do is complete
asynchronous courses and complete the
program steps that you're working with
now once you're added to a program once
you have been put in the program you've
completed registration you should see
the badge come up down here
uh you will have asynchronous courses
which once you start a course and you
have completed any aspect of that course
whether it's the first part of a lesson
or the first lesson
you'll see it show up here and it'll
show you the percentage that you've
completed you can see here i've
completed python course one
now there's a certificate associated
with each individual course now the
certificate will look a little different
once you've completed your program but
you'll receive something very similar
it'll look something like this and like
i mentioned though it'll be customized
to the per to the institution you're
coming from so if you're lsu it'll look
a little different lbr and it'll look a
little different and the individual that
signs this here for you will also be
different so for example lsu you'd have
dr gus casullis here
lvrn you're likely to have uh dr chris
taylor
and so on and so forth this is kind of
what your certificate will look like
once you've completed the training
there's also another way to access your
programs
if once you've been added to the program
you can go to your profile page you can
click on programs and your program
should come up here and it'll also show
you how
many of the components of each lecture
have been completed so today was the
first lecture for introduction to
bioinformatics and it became available
i'm going to open a new tab so come back
here at a moment
so this is what the uh page looks like
you'll see your profile information pop
up here but you can see here here's
today's selection uh lesson here's the
additional resources which for those of
you that want to complete um the
information beforehand
to get into the more advanced training
models here's where you're going to find
what you need to access you got to
complete all of these before you can be
added to the other uh lesson plan
and then once you've completed
everything in this particular lesson you
have to go here and you have to hit
complete lesson for it to be tagged as
complete and once you complete
all of the lessons associated with that
you'll get the certificate for the
program